t14 damn right welcome to wildstar this
is devspeak this disclaimer be as
hardcore this video covers the subject
we've talked about for a while and we
haven't really shown anything well
that's about to end because it's time to
unleash rays oh I'm sorry
see raids and wildstar are what we
always thought raids should be
for those who aren't hardcore raids are
120 240 lunatics rush headlong into a
nightmarish scenario of pure carnage and
impossible odds why because our hardcore
and in wildstar we've made sure that the
experience is fun and it's all thanks to
wild stars combat system if you've seen
our videos you know that we communicate
both player and enemy attacks using
Telegraph's
in the open world this makes combat feel
clear dynamic and reactive
it makes dungeons feel dangerous and
exciting and it makes raids insane
the Telegraph's are only a part of what
make our rates challenging for starters
they're ginormous try six bosses ten
mini bosses in five events or say seven
bosses 16 mini bosses and two rooms that
are also bosses and when it comes to
mini bosses we don't mess around these
fights are complex so what's a boss like
that check it
parkour Telegraph base trades keep even
the hardest encounters in the game
feeling completely unpredictable no
website walkthrough will prepare you for
the randomized chaos being thrown in
every direction but don't worry because
thanks to Telegraph's you'll know
exactly what you did wrong yeah that and
working together is a big deal in our
rigs what are you sleeping so we've made
sure that teamwork is fun
whether you're dropping down a heal
grappling teammates back to safety or
drawing fire to keep the room from being
destroyed our raids pit players against
the environments themselves rooms get
corrupted light on fire explode and with
such a clear way to communicate danger
we can achieve a level of complexity
that you wouldn't believe parkour now
what do you get for surviving these
mind-bending gauntlets of fear and
adrenaline showers of loot and we make
sure that every big accomplishment
whether it's mini bosses events for
challenges comes with little and it
looks good parkour so you think you're
that special breed of crazy parkour the
kind who drinks adrenaline for breakfast
parkland you might want to check out our
raids
we dare you
bow and hit us up on social media double
dog dare the devs are listening
would you like to subscribe to more
videos by the way you want to know what
else is hardcore
that's me on drums